hey what's going on hey baby
is the money morning podcast for October
8 2017 what's going on
yes I'm singing a little bit of Tom
Petty I was lucky enough to be at the
Florida Gators game in the swamp
against the yellow sand Tigers and that
[ __ ] SEC football 80,000 people
whatever the [ __ ] it is going absolutely
apeshit and they had this great tribute
which I'm sure somebody saw the clips
online of the whole stadium saying I
won't back down was [ __ ] on you know
it sucks the guy died you know but he
leaves all that great music and all that
what I would have yeah it's a great
[ __ ] that's a great life you know I
mean considering all this [ __ ] that
[ __ ] happens nowadays the fact that
that guy was able to make it into his
sixties the very least still sucks he
died you know but whatever was it great
it was [ __ ] awesome you know what's
hilarious as if you were there
everybody's sang the [ __ ] out of that
first verse and then when the second
verse came along
you saw the radio fans and then the real
Tom Petty fans right everybody knew the
first Birdseye whoa back damn Noah
staying
I don't know worse damn my ground and
then all of a sudden the [ __ ] so
everybody knew the words and then it
gets the second verse listen to it every
this kind of well
[Music]
everybody's just waiting for that hey
baby
there ain't no easy way out right so
anyways we went to the swamp out there
in in Gainesville Georgia where Tom
Petty is from evidently I didn't I
didn't know that till he died and I knew
he's from Florida yet another great
musician from Florida right you get all
the [ __ ] Allman Brothers from down
there you got Tom Petty I don't know
where the Heartbreakers are front but
you know I mean he met him so they had
to be somewhere near Florida right
somewhere in the [ __ ] lower 48 but
Jesus Christ did did that Stadium Ben
Hill [ __ ] Stadium this AKA the swamp
did that thing ever live up to its
[ __ ] name my god we had upper deck
seats and it was was uh it was just
[ __ ] it was ridiculous well we go up
there and they had like the aluminum
seats up top just like the old Patriots
Stadium you know and if you stood up
during the wintertime whenever he had
the big winter coats on if you stood up
too long after a good play or most
likely a disappointing play back then
when you went to sit back down you lost
your seat and then you were just sort of
standing up you couldn't sit down and
then people would Pelt you with hot dogs
and [ __ ] snowballs and all that [ __ ]
and you know what you did you laughed
and all your friends laughed at ya you
didn't make a [ __ ] you didn't have a
cell phone to make a video and turn
yourself into a victim you know so
anyways we were sitting up there and you
literally had to just walk back into the
tunnel and with all that heat coming off
the field and all those people there
like literally were you walked into the
stadium became like a wind tunnel so and
I was going out there man and I'm gonna
tell you right now there was a bunch of
people just [ __ ] sitting down all
shapes and sizes all ages from kids all
the way to old people just sitting down
like yell I gotta take a good [ __ ]
10-minute break here or I think I'm
gonna [ __ ] die and then mercifully
the Sun started to go by the way it's
October October felt like [ __ ] August
and the Sun filing went down and it was
a great game I know you know the Gators
were missing their starting quarterback
and I also know obviously LSU had that
horrible [ __ ] loss last week to the
Trojans Troy and so was a big win for
them it was just a [ __ ] who's a great
game unfortunately I kid missed that
field goal
everyone's chant his name Eddie Eddie
you know I don't want to happen to
[ __ ] kid missed the extra point you
kind of suck cuz I would love to see an
overtime but uh there was this one LSU
fan this old guy just he was [ __ ]
hilarious even like late get offenses is
annoying as he was he was just this old
guy and he would do these stupid dances
whenever LSU had like a big play he
looked ridiculous and was making a
complete ass of himself all the while
having the best time of his life and and
everyone oh it's just it's one of those
just one of those great [ __ ] moments
why you go to sports and all that [ __ ]
and uh you know we had we had a great
time we didn't pay for [ __ ] Parkin
either then we found out why afterwards
because we were so buried in but uh it
was just awesome to finally go their
legendary school legendary [ __ ] field
and I actually learned this about that
field is that that field is what is in
like the top 20 biggest stadiums in the
United States here they are right here
Michigan number one number two Penn
State then Ohio State Texas A&M
Tennessee LSU Alabama University of
Texas USC Georgia that's the top ten
then UCLA the Cotton Bowl Nebraska
Florida comes in at number fourteen and
I was pretty psyched as far as the top
ten I've been to every [ __ ] one of
those stadiums except for Penn State and
what's the other one
Michigan Texas A&M Tennessee I've been
at Tennessee so I got a [ __ ] knock
those out alright I got to try to do
that [ __ ] I know it's [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] but this is what this podcast is
this podcast is stupid [ __ ]
alright stupid [ __ ] that doesn't [ __ ]
matter and then listen to me
you know all these [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know I been getting letters lately a
really heavy variety it's I don't
[ __ ] do that on here you're listening
to the wrong [ __ ] podcast is enough
of that out there this place is to
forget you [ __ ] troubles [ __ ]
[ __ ] some douchebag sent me this
[ __ ] email the name of the email was
[ __ ] America and then he goes on to Cru
present his argument about gun control
it's like buddy you started it off with
[ __ ] America like how would you how is
the people that you want to listen to
this going to listen to it after that so
I won't be reading that one you know
what I mean at least [ __ ] people
scream and it [ __ ] yelling about this
about that you know what I mean every
time there's a big [ __ ] tragedy you
know what I love now I love how
everybody's got a [ __ ] way in now
right and then like it becomes my
favorite things is celebrities react to
the hurricane you know I mean like oh oh
good I need to know what JLo thinks
about a category-5 Oh was she was she
upset that that happened to Houston who
wouldn't be who the [ __ ] wouldn't be I
don't [ __ ] I just don't understand
why they do that
I've never [ __ ] understood they'll be
like a [ __ ] earthquake and then it's
always like hashtag [ __ ] thinking
about you know wherever the [ __ ]
earthquake hit you know it's funny about
those [ __ ] accounts most of those
like if you're smart I guess you know
you don't do your own account you have
somebody else do it
so whenever anything bad happens they
actually had somebody else doing it for
the person so they don't get in trouble
they don't say the wrong [ __ ] thing
just everything he's just become that I
missed that whole story about Cam Newton
he said some smart aleck Lee thing to a
[ __ ] female reporter right and rather
than her just settling with him being
like he can't why don't you go [ __ ]
yourself and then they laugh it off and
they both drink a Bud Light or something
a Miller Lite like they used to how it
used to go down
all of a sudden now he showed ups to the
game today for some reason
dressed like a pimp like I don't know
what and then he's got like a [ __ ]
rosie the riveter all these positive
[ __ ] about women I don't I just I don't
[ __ ] I don't under that it's just one
[ __ ] apology after another meanwhile
the world is going to hell in a [ __ ]
handbasket and I gotta [ __ ] sit here
and and and I'm gonna watch that I need
to see the resolution of that like these
two [ __ ] adults cannot solve this
amongst themselves I swear to God I had
was half listening to Cam Newton I swear
to God he was talking to Rosie the
Riveter as if it was a real person am I
out of my mind or that wasn't that like
a caricature that represented women
working in World War two was there
really a woman named Rosie and her
middle name was the and the last name
was Riveter I might be wrong you know by
all means let me look this up before I
have to have a press conference and
[ __ ] apologize to somebody here we go
Rosie the Riveter Rosie the Riveter
alright Rosie the rivers a cultural icon
yes I swear to god he was [ __ ] talking
like it was a my Paulette maybe he
wasn't that will be [ __ ] hilarious and
then lastly I'd like to apologize to
Rosie the Riveter I know she did a lot
of things she riveted a lot of rivets
back down there by the river and I
apologize here's something I wish people
in the press could do I wish they could
get that balls broken a little bit more
especially if you got if you kind of go
in the locker room you know what I mean
you gotta [ __ ] go in there
people are gonna bust your chops like
the athletes like they should be able to
sit there and be like what did you say
you bald fat [ __ ] who couldn't run
thirty yards without having a heart
what was your question about Mike my
decision in the second quarter why can't
they do that I don't understand why they
can't do that what'd you say lady you
addressed me as news sports reporter now
go [ __ ] [ __ ] yourself that stupid-ass
story it will get more [ __ ] coverage
than pharmaceutical companies basically
being heroin dealers you know what I
mean they're not gonna [ __ ] with that
because they advertise on that channel
but God forbid somebody throws one high
and tight at somebody with a [ __ ]
clamp and all of a sudden all Jesus the
whole [ __ ] world stops I'm not saying
he shouldn't apologize they should
[ __ ] handle it this thing he didn't
say it to me the [ __ ] am I sitting there
watching it for I don't know he lost
like advertising money I mean who can't
even [ __ ] remember like what wouldn't
you know the only one thing I can ever
remember this is some of the greatest
advertising I guess because I can
remember with Shaquille O'Neal did it
did a bunch of Buick ads and that was
the funniest [ __ ] thing ever because
and a lot of people instantly when they
saw that it's like Shaq doesn't drive a
[ __ ] Buick it's one of the top 50 NBA
players of all time the [ __ ] did he do
with his money that he's driving at
Buick even if he blew all his goddamn
money from being a player he still got a
TV gig he's not driving up Buick
he can't even [ __ ] fit in one maybe
though that [ __ ] Roadmaster from back
in the 50s I cut the roof off a Riviera
maybe I don't know take out the front
seat he could sit in the back end I
don't know actually Shaq is memorable I
don't know why he does that and then he
has the one with the little monopoly guy
the general which just looks like the
cheesiest [ __ ] insurance ever you
know and then Shaq does that you know
I'm not really smiling I'm just smiling
because I'm gonna get paid you know
where he has the under and the overbite
he just puts his top teeth on his bow
I'm teeth I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about
I use like I said I usually don't
[ __ ] do these when I fly in the same
day I just of course I have no [ __ ]
time I have a million [ __ ] things to
do
buh buh buh what else what else what
else how should I address this I will
address this the big [ __ ] story that
everybody's talking about out there I am
of the firm [ __ ] belief I am of the
firm [ __ ] belief this is a new theory
I'm not saying I'm right but I am of the
[ __ ] belief that the [ __ ]
attention that they give to these
[ __ ] lunatics is why more than ever
people do that lunatic [ __ ] like do you
remember when Kim Kardashian she made
that sex tape and then all of a sudden
somebody got a hold of it and then it
went out there and then it became like
this porno tape and up until then that
was unbelievably embarrassing and it
[ __ ] ruined you and then that was it
that was [ __ ] it but somehow she came
out the other side with the TV show and
it's now like a [ __ ] like an icon
multi [ __ ] millionaire and right after
that happened what happened a bunch of
women who wouldn't have done that [ __ ]
went out and tried to do that [ __ ] cuz
they saw it and what stopped it was none
of it none of them [ __ ] made it
however if they started [ __ ] making
it and started getting attention the way
these lunatics do I saw on the cover of
People magazine they're like going this
is the deadliest yada yada yada of all
[ __ ] time you're given these these
[ __ ] lunatics a number two now shoot
for cuz the same way I said on TV and
sat at home on TV and I'm said oh look
at that stand at list stand-up comedy it
looks cool I want to [ __ ] do that
lunatics want to do this other [ __ ] I am
of a firm [ __ ] belief they should not
[ __ ] shouldn't say the dude's name
that's it you go in you whack the guy
you throw him in a [ __ ] incinerator
and then you throw his ashes in a
[ __ ] sewer that's it all right and
then you take care whoever got [ __ ]
hurt that's what you do all right but
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] that you then put
it on the top and then you know one of
these [ __ ] channels they're gonna be
they're gonna be gonna do like they do
with this
killers you know you never know the
victims names you just know that those
[ __ ] people
and all the [ __ ] celebrities you know
who if they even run their goddamn
accounts then they got a [ __ ] comment
about it the celebrity reaction to the
tragedy where they weren't at you know
something else [ __ ] I'm on a rant you
know what else I'd like I liked all
these douchebags who were taking videos
of themselves they weren't anywhere near
it hey just letting everybody know that
I'm alright it's like yeah dude you're
twenty [ __ ] miles down the street who
the [ __ ] even knew you were there who
are you making this for you can't just
text your friends and be like yeah dude
I'm cool I don't know everything has
gets got to be about everybody's got to
make it about themselves I [ __ ] it
drives me up the [ __ ] wall
drives me up the [ __ ] wall I have no
solution for this [ __ ] but I do firmly
[ __ ] believe that they have to stop
making these these [ __ ] lunatics
famous and ranking you know the body
count I might be wrong
the [ __ ] do I know I'm a comedian okay
I'll apologize next week I'll wear a
[ __ ] Ted Bundy button on a pimp hat
and I'll [ __ ] apologize to somebody I
guess I don't know what alright there
you go I'm done I'm done with my [ __ ]
rant there anyways what else what else
oh yes I went to the [ __ ] UH the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers game not justified
that [ __ ] just drives me nuts
it's not about so-and-so's [ __ ]
reactions about the people that were
there and then the people came in and
[ __ ] helped the people it's not about
the lunatic that did it it's about those
people that's what's about it's not
about you down the street
he's [ __ ] there and I [ __ ] the DJ
stopped playing records and I was like
whoa what's going on anyways I had a I
went to uh I went to the [ __ ]
Buccaneers game the pirate ship one not
the choo-choo train it's very confusing
for Boston sports fans okay we got one
with a pirate ship on with the choo-choo
train and our fans will [ __ ] great
great goddamn fans love the stadium and
you know it's funny you could
that they built the pirate ship first
and then they put the flat screen the
giant screen afterwards because the
Buccaneers won Super Bowl I believe the
2002 season and I remember vaguely
remember them they brought the flag up
and they put it up on the ship which was
cool you know what I mean that
Buccaneers they're pirates or whatever
they got the ship or whatever right but
now they got this giant flat screen so
the [ __ ] championship flag was
blocking the TV screen so now they're
Super Bowl flag is made out of mesh it
is difficult to see it's like you want a
Super Bowl it should be a giant [ __ ]
flag just move the ship or [ __ ] put
the championship flag somewhere else
maybe they have another one I couldn't
see it but that struck me as funny you
know what I mean it also made me like
Tampa Bay well I'm just gonna look at
these please [ __ ] ok don't they don't
have a zillion dollars that just adding
onto this thing like somebody bought a
house then they got a little money they
put a [ __ ] addition on it you know
and somebody bought a boat then a
recession happened you know then he came
back to the good times he bought a big
[ __ ] TV and then they they got to
adjust the sails you know it's why you
ever see like a degenerate gambler
sitting there playing cards you always
see like like signs of when they want
they'll having a really shiny bracelet
you know dirty hat but like $500
sunglasses it's just like it's up and
down up and down up and down look the
whole [ __ ] wardrobe dirty jeans with
like a [ __ ] wearing a mink um anyway
so we went there had a great time was
embarrassed by this one Patriots fan who
just would not sit down he was just
[ __ ] you know this guy with like 140
pounds and he never got this [ __ ] kicked
out of him clearly and he just wouldn't
sit down and people argue well it's his
right if he wants to stand up it's like
but this you know this is this guy he
brought his girlfriend she's short she
can't see around there's nobody standing
in front of him and this Patriots friend
was like you know threatening to punch
him in his forgot my punch he ain't you
[ __ ] it was really like Patriots fans
arguing with Patriots v was [ __ ]
hilarious I saw that
we even won the game we came out of the
stadium and I saw there was a group of
[ __ ] Patriots fans and they were like
arguing with each other I just heard the
FEGLI or this guy going to why can't I
wear a Tedy Bruschi Jersey but if you
can [ __ ] Weibull it--and then they
just kind of walked by but anyways it
was a it was a great time and I we had a
great show out there and then the next
day old sober bill fifty three [ __ ]
days in we rode up to the swamp and
listened to Ozzie on the way up because
on the way up there you kind of go not
you get like within like 10 miles I
think if you take the 75 north of where
Randy Rhoads died so we listened to some
early Ozzy Burley solo Ozzy I should say
on the way up and just had a great time
pulled in [ __ ] smoked a cigar had a
great [ __ ] time got to go to another
SEC game it was it was a great time
definitely a great time so thank it
everybody came out I will definitely
definitely be back I think the next time
I come back maybe I'll go back for
Florida State I've been to Miami I've
been to I've been to the Gator so the
only thing left really is Florida State
and then there's that one like is it
Central Florida there's another one that
always has a lot of NFL players is it
southern Florida something like that I
can't remember whatever whatever I'll
figure it out um you know that Patriots
fan wouldn't sit down he had a Tom Brady
[ __ ] Jersey on and salmon shorts and
every was going dude she sat down she
set the [ __ ] down first time somebody
said to sit out and go turns already cuz
you asked me nicely little [ __ ] little
[ __ ] guy and not like a stocky now I
got tied Oh me built little guy this was
just a slight man and I don't know was
taking sports way too seriously I
remember we got a first down
like a big first down the end of the
game and he did like that you know that
remember that Jordan thing that he would
do
we'd make a fist and he [ __ ] bring
his arm up you know when he sank the
[ __ ] shot and it was over he [ __ ]
did that you know when when the Patriots
got a first down he had [ __ ] lower
jaw sticking out [ __ ] as
I said I don't know what the [ __ ] just
looking at a lunatic and he just
wouldn't sit down and finally bartnik
got him to sit down I can't tell you
what he said I can tell what it started
with he said hey Giselle sit the [ __ ]
down and I can't say the rest cuz
everybody you know everybody everybody
gets all [ __ ] uptight now but you
know what it was effective
he sat the [ __ ] down and did not get up
for the rest of the game and when he did
he said few times he got up on big plays
and every else got up and they sat down
then he was finally a [ __ ] gentleman
about here's an interesting questing
Paul virzi asked me on the ride back he
goes do you believe in destiny and I
told him no he goes down I'm just asking
like do you believe like Michael Jordan
was destined to be the greatest
basketball I was like no I don't I don't
and he was saying that he did but he
believed that you it's just you you have
your destiny and one of your destiny is
like that's what the [ __ ] your destiny
is and I just don't believe it I don't
you don't I mean I think you're born
with the talent and if you work your
[ __ ] ass off you can make it happen
however how [ __ ] up the world is
there's a bunch of people that can take
your destiny away from you like you can
[ __ ] have you know your destiny is to
be whatever you're gonna be a doctor and
[ __ ] blah blah blah and then you go
out one day you drive down the street
and you get hit and by a drunk driver
and you die so like that was your that
your destiny was to get hit by a drunk
driver I don't I don't think that I
don't think it is I don't think it is I
think if the world was a perfect place
everybody would reach their potential
but um you know I've said this before
like the world doesn't give a [ __ ] about
your dream whether it comes true or not
it's [ __ ] sucks and even if you make
all the right choices and all that [ __ ]
you know some [ __ ] lunatic can you
know take it away from you so see this
is why I don't talk about that [ __ ] well
you cuts asking me about it I don't want
to [ __ ] talk about it but the world's
depressing enough as it is
all right the all things comedy [ __ ]
Festival podcast read we're having our
first all things comedy festival at the
end of the month October 26 to the 29th
in Phoenix Arizona I'm gonna be there
recording my first ever live Monday
morning podcast I don't know how I'm
gonna do it if I'm gonna address the
crowd if I'm just gonna come walking out
if I don't know what I'm gonna [ __ ]
through Doug Stanhope the great Doug
Stanhope the legendary Doug stand out
the the national treasure that is Doug
Stanhope he's doing his podcast at the
Orpheum Theatre Bert Kreischer
Ari Shaffir Jen Kirkman and the crab
feast are also on the lineup basically
we're taking over downtown Phoenix with
the pop-up podcast studio and the whole
network is going to be there if you're
in the Phoenix area come hang out with
us go to all things comedy com2 get your
tickets I can't wait to do this man this
is gonna be fun as hell it's really
gonna be fun as hell I know this has
been like a [ __ ] up podcast because
I'm trying to talk around a lot of [ __ ]
in it you know and yet another one of my
[ __ ] friends died co-workers died and
it's just [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks it sucks
you know Ralphie make the great Ralphie
make unfortunately passed away this
weekend and just legit legit legit
[ __ ] murderer
that guy just [ __ ] killed he killed
him the first time I saw I think it was
was at the late 90s when he came out I
believe it was the late 90s he came out
and there was already another comic
there bigger guy Ron Lester who also has
since [ __ ] passed away unfortunately
which I didn't even realize he died last
year so rest in peace to him and you
know those big guys had to deal with
like clubs they kind of had this thing
where they just you know they had their
big guy
comic and it was like weird they almost
were like we're in competition with each
other and then Ron ended up getting all
this acting work and he just sort of
stopped doing stand-up but Ralphy came
in it just was just a [ __ ] was a
force to be dealt with and you know that
just [ __ ] sucks remember you always
telling me he was gonna teach me how to
smoke meat or whatever like that you
know because he was just going you don't
know how to do a bill he's like you from
[ __ ] Massachusetts I'm from Tennessee
I'm gonna show you how to do it blah
blah and of course we both got busy we
never got around to doing it and I know
he's got two little kids so I imagine
someone's putting together a benefit
somewhere for it so I imagine I'll be
doing that but yeah it was just a
[ __ ] just a [ __ ] sad sad time god
damn it I remember I did if I did a
traveling virus tour with him I did a
lot of gigs with that guy like a lot of
those sort of you know I don't know he
was yeah much younger than me but not
much I'm 49 he was 45 we came up roughly
he started younger than I did that's
what it was cuz he kind of started at
the same time I want to say so he was
always as seasoned as I was so I always
felt I felt like we were the same age
even though I was older than he was so
as we went up I just a lot of comedy
festivals a lot of tours the tours
always got better he was the guy who
told you this he was Ralphie may was the
[ __ ] guy I remember I did this gig
Chilkoot Charlie's which is a great gig
but they're [ __ ] accommodations where
was the worst accommodations I had was
up in Alaska and I showed up and the bed
literally was broken and it looked like
it looked like the bedbugs like left
like they couldn't hack it we're like
[ __ ] this and I remember the boards were
busted in them the mattress was like
[ __ ] and that a giant crease in it
and [ __ ] and I will
you know raised Catholic or whatever so
rather than expressing that you didn't
like it you just just took it just was
like alright I gotta be tough I got a
[ __ ] I told you the first night he
spent in [ __ ] my walkthrough bedroom
my first night in New York City I felt
this thing on my chest and I turned on
the light and there was a roach crawling
across my chest and I flicked it off my
[ __ ] chest
I didn't even kill it I just thought it
was like oh this is what I got it I got
it like I got to get myself tough enough
to handle this like I'm gonna live with
bugs crawling over me yeah I'm a [ __ ]
lunatic I don't know what so anyway so I
do the gig and I stay in that [ __ ] all
so I end up going down to the Laugh
Factory like a week at ten days later
and I walk in growl he was always
hanging out always did the work you know
and I came down and he was just like Ava
what's up I say hey man he goes wait
coming from that's what we always asked
each other there was certain guys you
know that were just Road dogs Hedberg
Ralphie
Stanhope Geraldo like these were these
were the guys every time I went to a
[ __ ] club they either were just there
or they were gonna be there the next
week I just when I was coming up we were
all kind of close in the same rooms like
Hedberg was I had a little bit ahead of
me as was Stanhope and those but those
they were roughly my age and those were
guys that I really looked up to as far
as like you know they were just they
were like they started a few years
before me so they were just sort of
cutting this path and then their style
is like I want to do that I want to say
what the [ __ ] I want to say on stage I
don't want to do what they're doing I
want to you know be who the [ __ ] I am
the way they are was basically it so
anyways we used to always ask each other
where you coming from where you're going
or whatever right whenever I ran to any
of those guys and so I run into Ralphie
and he's goes we coming from I was like
I did that gig up in Alaska Chilkoot
Charlie's like oh [ __ ] I did that gig
great gig I was like
great kick and I was like Jesus Christ
ago how about that comedy condo and
Ralphie got this serious look on his
face he goes he goes I didn't stay there
I go what do you mean he goes man he
goes I took one look at that place he
goes I'm not staying in and they got me
a hotel room and I just looked in a mine
that said you can do that and he laughed
it goes yeah he goes what the [ __ ] are
they gonna do he goes it's Alaska we're
gonna get another [ __ ] comedian to
fly six hours all the way up there have
some lumberjack go on stage and tell
some street jokes it's like just just
say no and that was one of those things
I [ __ ] learned I was just like
alright and after that after that if I
went someplace I just and it was a
[ __ ] I just said no and if they just
said we're not paying for a hotel room I
said you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
pay for a [ __ ] hotel room and it was
worth it to just be able to go back to a
[ __ ] place where you felt safe and
you didn't feel like there was gonna be
bugs crawling on you or somebody just
all over the [ __ ] bar god knows what
[ __ ] some chick on her period not even
gonna tell you that [ __ ] story every
comedian knows that [ __ ] one their
goddamn [ __ ] crime scene cleaning
lady quit the big rumor was the
bloodstains was still on the [ __ ]
windowsill I swear to god this is all
this is all this is not myths so goddamn
it Ralphie I'm gonna miss your buddy
[ __ ] anyways alright let's get into
something now that I talked about
another dead friend let's talk about
that so how about some advertising here
Lou crate everybody give it a loot crate
be the envy of your friends and get your
100% exclusive crates at loot crate calm
/ burrow and enter my code bird to save
$3.00 off on any new subscription
October October's Luke rake theme is
mythical I cannot believe these people
are still advertising this is can only
mean one thing that you guys are into
this [ __ ] can somebody please write in
to the podcast and explain to me what
this is I do
picture this is a giant trunk of
lightsabers in underoos Lu crate offers
an epic range of pop-culture items for
less than $20 a month monthly wearables
and accessories with Koch classics and
your favorite and your favorite
franchises franchise to me as McDonald's
if you want to get fancy get a bigger
box with the innie with even bigger loot
with Lu crate DX want to geek out your
pet try loot pets offer expires 9th
October 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific you hear
the stories the whispers of creatures
and beings beyond imaginations no I
don't I don't even know what you're
talking about
you hear the stories the whispers of
creatures and beings beyond imagination
is that like a Joel Olsteen quote you
hear the story the whispers God God
wants you to have creatures and beings
beyond beyond imagination join us as we
peer into the shadows oh jesus [ __ ]
creeps and look into the other realms
for October's truly mythical collection
get unreal items from Marvel
Ghostbusters stranger things and Buffy
the Vampire Slayer
alright I know what all those things are
one lucky subscriber will also win a
mega crate of seriously epic proportions
you have until the 19th at 9 Pete what
the what the [ __ ] do you get in it
stranger thing like yo-yo or some shut
up
just subscribers but evidently you guys
know what it is because they keep
advertising and receive that month's
crate and when the cutoff happens that's
it it's over
go to Luke Raycom slash burn enter my
code birbee you are to save $3 off on
any new subscription today you should
get a trunk full of stuff evidently
every [ __ ] month is it a nice trunk
do you get to keep it or is it
disposable Dollar Shave Club everybody
buddy uh everyone knows Dollar Shave
Club ships amazing raises for a few
bucks at this store
there are too many options and you can
you can't tell the difference between
any of them then if you have any
questions the clerk usually doesn't know
the difference or there's only one
person working the store it becomes a
major pain in the ass you got to wait 20
minutes for someone to find the key
right Dollar Shave Club makes an easy
and convenient for you to upgrade your
shave and your bathroom now you don't
have to set foot in a store to get
high-quality shape and grooming products
Dollar Shave Club delivers them right to
your door just like their races
everything is super high quality and
will leave you looking and feeling
amazing for only $5 this starter set
features their executive razor and trial
size versions of their most popular
products that help you stay fresh and
clean in your first box you'll receive
their shave butter body wash in one wipe
butt wipes you will also receive their
executive razor which includes their
premium weighty handle and focused set
of cartridges after the first box
replacement cartridges are sent for only
a few dollars a month
this offer is exclusively available at
Dollar Shave Club com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / Dollar Shave
club's high quality products will have
you covered from face cheeks to butt
cheeks there's no better time to try the
club all right oh look who's here it's
all zip what a firing could be easy more
streamlined and less time-consuming so
even when you're busy you could still be
smart about the way you hire with zip
recruiter you can post your job to over
100 of the web's leading job boards with
just one click so you can rest easy
knowing your job is being seen by the
right candidates then zip puts it at
smart matching technology to work
actively notifying qualified candidates
about your job within minutes of posting
so you receive the best possible matches
it's like a dating site except you're
hiring people to work at your company
and not to suck you
you can even get a head start on the
interview process by adding screening
questions to your job post to help
identify the most qualified candidates
so you don't have to waste time sorting
through a stack of resumes to find the
perfect fit
no wonder 80% of employers who post on
zip get on quality candidates through
this site in just one day and the
easy-to-use it dashboard lets you manage
your heart lets you manage your hiring
process from start to finish all in one
place the smartest way to smartest way
to hire find out today why zip recruit
has been used by growing businesses of
all sizes and industries to find the
most qualified job candidates with the
media results and right now my listeners
can post jobs on sip recruiter for free
that's right for free just go to zip
recruit calm slash / while my time high
that's it / / alright the last one
everybody it's helix HELOCs you know
there are a ton of online math mattress
retailers popping up these days are
there I have no idea all with a
one-size-fits-all solution to a better
sleep guess what one size fits all
doesn't work helix sleep offers
something that doesn't exist anywhere
else a mattress personalized to your
unique preferences and sleeping styles
that won't set you back thousands of
dollars go to hellix leap calm slash /
take their simple two to three minutes
sleep quiz they'll build a custom
mattress that would be the best thing
you ever slept on for couples you know
what I would love I would love a
mattress that when I fall asleep with a
glass of booze in my hand it doesn't
spill on my pajama scene but that's the
old me and I gotta be honest with you I
miss the old me and I'll tell you right
now I would be as great as I feel not
drinking for the last fifty three days
I'll tell you right now all freckles is
getting thirsty for the couple's they
even personalize each side of the
mattress butterflies for her big old
titties for you
everyone from GQ Mazdas magazine to
cosmopolitan to the new york times are
all talking about well you pay for
advertising I'm talking about helix and
once you try it out you'll know why your
custom your custom mattress arrives
direct to your door in a week and
shipping is completely free try it for
100 nights if you don't love it you
don't love that [ __ ] mattress
goddammit we'll come back they'll pick
it up gross and refund you in full
now he's picturing them showing up and
like [ __ ] the Walter White hazmat
suit for our [ __ ] monkey pinky shut
go to helix sleep calm slash burn right
now and you'll get $50 towards your
custom metrics that's HELOCs sleep calm
slash bar for $50 off your order
helix sleep calm slash bar alright let's
go to the questions for the week yet the
doot-doot doot-doot all right [ __ ] you
America I'm not reading that one are my
mom and her boyfriend being selfish or
am i by the way the person wrote [ __ ]
you America I'm not saying that you
didn't make some decent points there but
it's a waste of time for you to write
that for me to read it after you write
that alright why don't you grow the [ __ ]
up and come up with a more mature title
and I'll read that one how about that
how about that how about that and then
I'll wait into the topic of gun control
is if I know a [ __ ] thing about it or
even have a solution are my mom and her
boyfriend being selfish or am i dear
bill I'm 19 and live at home working to
get this carpenter's apprenticeship with
a local union and please don't say my
name on the podcast well why would you
give me your name you [ __ ] [ __ ]
about two months ago
my mom's boyfriend started coming over
and staying over to a point where he was
practically living there gross they
would stay here in this place exist they
would stay here in his place exactly
half the time the first three days he
was here I heard their headboard day and
night I was like who the [ __ ] is this
guy oh my god oh boy oh boy
my mom said they had been
friends for a year now but only went on
two dates I asked her to have him not be
here as much and if she could just come
home without him I don't want him I
don't want to talk to my mom with this
guy right [ __ ] there nothing changed
until one night I snapped and went on a
rampage my mom called the cops on me
that night and now the half the time
they would they would have spent here is
just my mom now but here's the kicker so
that's good you got him out of the house
but here's a kicker two weeks later he
proposed oh boy when my mom talked to me
about it she asked if I had a problem
with her wearing the ring literally the
question was only about the ring not the
engagement I feel totally disrespected
by him and my mom for not seeing that
this guy has no respect for her son I've
decided to join the Coast Guard because
the Union stuff is taking too long I
would have just moved in with my dad if
every day he didn't just bring out how
much of a [ __ ] my mom is Jesus Christ
dude this is awful man I'm sorry you're
going through this and now his life
sucks and I can't and I can't be around
that I'm ready to walk away and just
drop my family and Tyree entirely my mom
swears this guy's a super nice but he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about her life as a
mother and subsequently me or maybe I'm
wrong I just wanted to get another
opinion because I'm ready to just cut
off everyone in my family and walk away
thanks - go [ __ ] yourself well it's your
mom and your dad you don't want to do
that you know I can see why you want to
get out of the house when you get here
somebody banging your [ __ ] mother I
mean Jesus Christ hey mom how about
doggy style you know what I mean you
always got to be in the [ __ ]
missionary position something for
Christ's sake can you slide down the bed
a little more all right well until you
move out I would recommend getting some
wireless headphones
maybe those Bose once that block out the
[ __ ] noise I don't know what to tell
you dude
I wouldn't join the Coast Guard unless
you wanted to
well the Coast Guard sounds that sounds
like a great [ __ ] job to me although
I did [ __ ] talk about you know that
time I went on that thing about like
whenever a [ __ ] hurricanes coming or
everybody's you know
going to safety like how everybody in
the Coast Guard is just like they've got
to be on pins and needles because they
know some dumb [ __ ] gonna take this
stupid boat out there and then when they
[ __ ] up and then they call to rescue him
these poor men and women gonna have to
go out and go fish them out alright so
what are you asking me here
I would not cut out your mother and your
father I would talk I would communicate
to your mother how you feel about that
guy and now you don't feel that he
respects you okay and that's the reason
you're leaving I guess and then I want
to talk to your dad saying you know dad
I would love to stay with you but all
you do is [ __ ] and say what a [ __ ] my
mother is and she's my mom and I'm sick
of listening to it alright just try to
say it in a nicer [ __ ] way but I know
doesn't sound like they're here on you
[ __ ] but here's the thing dude if you're
gonna be you can't you got to [ __ ]
clear the air with them because you
can't go into the coastguard in angry
[ __ ] lunatic because what's going to
happen is you're gonna get into a fight
or something because you're pissed off
at that [ __ ] douche who's banging
your mom and then that's gonna affect
your career so this is something that
I've been working on this is [ __ ]
brutal forgiving people like that guy
you got us somewhere in your head and
just forgive the guy for being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and so you get that off of you and
you know when you forgive somebody it
does it does a lot for you it gets it
off for you and then what you should be
focusing on is trying to figure out what
your dream is and start walking towards
it everyday and and creating a life that
isn't like what you grew up with so your
kids someday doesn't have to [ __ ]
deal with what you dealt with and you
know and that doesn't happen overnight
and the mistakes I made was I went out
thinking all right I want to I want to
change all this about what I didn't like
about growing up but then what happens
is you grew you gravitate towards what's
familiar and you end up reading I think
he kind of go out and recreated
inevitably and then you after dis man
- let's start over again least that's
what happened to me I'm up superimposing
whatever the [ __ ] happen to me but I
wouldn't come at your mother are you re
or your dad with anger I would just say
listen I I I forgive you I forgive you
I'm not a Buddhist I forgive you I
understand you gotta try to do what's
right for you
but this bothered me because X Y & Z and
just say tell you that's a dead you know
some I gotta forgive you for something
and now got his attention
I forgive you for every time that I came
over here and you went on and on about
and what a [ __ ] [ __ ] my mother was
alright I did a lot of damage and it did
so much damage that I have to sit here
and try to figure out how to forgive you
for that and then just stop talking I
see and listen to what he says okay if
he's any sort of a man his head's gonna
drop and he's gonna [ __ ] apologize to
you and he can you know and I'm not
saying then it all the anger you gonna
have towards him goes away right then
it you start that and if you guys work
on starting over from that point and
really [ __ ] work on it and really
[ __ ] communicate hopefully you can go
out into the world and not be an angry
young man like I was because I heard a
lot of people all right
there you go alright problem with
girlfriend dear Billiam I have a big
problem with my girlfriend with my lady
[Music]
I have a big problem with my girlfriend
if we've been dating well we've been
dating for the past three years and I
think I might want to marry her but for
the last month or so we've been having a
fight my sister and I are very close and
since my parents died last year in a car
crash we moved in together which for
some reason pissed her off I don't know
why well I mean where were you living
before that she probably after three
years wanted you to move in with her
probably wants a goddamn ring then for
some reason the fact that my sister and
my best friend still smoke pot and that
they are going then for some reason the
fact that my sister and my best friends
smoke pot and that they are dating as
well well she doesn't like that either I
admit it was weird for me at first but I
got used to it anyway the fight was
about the fact that she wants to move in
that she wants me to move in with her
yeah obviously but I don't want to and
she refuses to move in with me as long
as my sister is there I do love her and
all that stuff but this is something
that I just can't do my sister is in a
very fragile place right now and my
girlfriend can't get that or won't I
don't know what to do if possible can
you ask me I feel like women would
understand better well she's downstairs
dealing with my daughter here's the deal
with women did they work on a different
clock than we do all right so you just
took three years of her life all right
and all she's hearing is you know you
know that story the tell-tale heart
under the floorboards that's their
that's their [ __ ] womb all right they
have a finite amount of time where they
can have kids all right before used to
have to start doing some Buck Rogers
[ __ ] okay and women do not want to go
through that if they don't have to all
right so what she needs out of you is
some sort of [ __ ] commitment all
right and she was looking for that after
three years the fact that all she wanted
to do is move in she's being pretty cool
she should probably be going for the
[ __ ] ring depending on how old you
are and what I would do with if I was
you dude I would man the [ __ ] up and
either come in with two or I break up
with her one of the other although the
wild card is is that your parents died
last year in a car crash so you're
probably not in a place emotionally to
make that [ __ ] decision Jesus Christ
you know what [ __ ] everything that I
just said your parents died in a [ __ ]
car crash last year you got to look out
for your family members and if she can't
[ __ ] understand that then you know I
don't know what to tell you I guess you
got to figure out how many you're gonna
find out how much you love her you know
if if if you got to let it go maybe you
got to let it go I don't know I have no
[ __ ] idea
but I understand her side I've invested
three years in this and you moved in
with another woman and it's your sister
that seems like a step backwards to her
and that she has to move in she wanted
to [ __ ] she listen this chick wants
to marry you so she wanted to move in
and then have you guys have a bunch of
communal stuff because women think that
if you do that that you're not gonna
there's a less of a chance that you're
gonna break up with them they feel like
it's moving in a positive direction and
you went left
you took a left hand turn but life gave
you a [ __ ] left-hand turn so you're
both not wrong why don't you try that
just say to her look you're not wrong
for being mad at me and I'm also not
wrong for taking care of my sister and
then just stare at her and whoever talks
first loses soon something along those
lines you're not wrong and she's not
wrong she's not wrong after three years
to [ __ ] be like what the [ __ ] and
you're not wrong for looking out for
your sister when something like tragic
like that then she's [ __ ] nothing but
tragedy nowadays Jesus Christ sorry that
happens for you sir to you sir alright
geographically locked by marriage Jesus
there's just there's just no rail light
here hi bill love your work thank you
for the laughter hey something positive
I've been in a relationship since 2011
with a European woman that became a
marriage I am originally from South
America educated in the u.s. went to
fancy school there MIT look at you you
smart bastard
they got my PhD in Europe whoa la-dee-da
spread your brain all around the [ __ ]
world here we've been in a solid couple
our glue was out of love from
mountaineering mountain climbing is I
would did a mountaineering I don't know
what the [ __ ] that is that's some weird
sex [ __ ] or does that mean you you
[ __ ] it's not rock climbing
mountaineering you just walk up a
mountain yodeling and outdoor sports
[ __ ] is mountaineering
jieb had a wagon here I remember that I
remember a mountaineer about to nearing
Wikipedia you always have the answers
the term mountaineering describes the
port the the sport of mountain climbing
also rock climbing is what people do
with gyms now in mountaineering is if
you actually go up a mountain okay I get
it while some scholars identify
mountaineering related activity as
climbing parentheses rock and ice and
trekking up mountains others are also
adding backpacking hiking skiing oh
Jesus Christ I already see these groups
where mountaineering - we just take a
ski lift
alright mountaineering alright Jesus
Christ dude what are you [ __ ] James
Bond born in Africa went to MIT got your
PhD in Europe you [ __ ] client you
climb mountains other outdoor sports how
do you top mountain earrings huh
what are you doing I'm trying to think
how you topped at as far as outdoor
sports but now things are uh what else
do you do you grab cobras by the [ __ ]
tail and kiss him on the back of the
head by now things are a bit sour what
happened we away we'd always been a
solid copper our glue was out our love
for mountaineering in outdoor sports but
now things are a bit sour I don't see
how I can have a career here in this
continent and she's a working-class lady
who would suffer a lot from moving I
also have a good business possibility in
my home country Brazil Oh South America
they said Africa South America um okay
so you simply can't let that go I
developed somewhat somewhat of a scorn
for the paperwork required to simply
exit exist in Europe and would rather be
on my own live up to my own country
make my money and have the freedom to
explore my vast underdeveloped continent
but she wouldn't be able to come along
also for my high tech education most
good jobs are in the great US of A but
I'm also burnt out with visas and
permits and red flags I don't think I
have the strength to beg for a high-tech
job they will pay me less than my
business in Brazil other than that we
get along fine she's a solid partner but
not the type who would survive the third
world I think it's a no-brainer but I'm
lost
homebound and would love your thoughts
thank you Jesus yeah me too that's a
huge you gonna you gonna ask a [ __ ]
comedian who doesn't know you to make
that decision I think at the end of the
day whenever it comes down to stuff like
this you have to make decisions that are
gonna make you happy all right if you
don't you're not gonna be happy and then
you're gonna make the person you with
miserable however if there's kids
involved then you know you got a man up
and suffer it doesn't sound like you got
any [ __ ] kids all right if you're
married to this woman and you don't have
any [ __ ] kids that you know if you're
gonna start getting resentful and you
just gonna argue and argue and argue and
argue all you guys are gonna do is take
great years young healthy [ __ ] years
of your life we should be having a good
time and you're gonna just make each
other [ __ ] miserable
all right so either you figure out how
to [ __ ] to stay with her or she comes
along with you or you go your separate
ways but if you need to you know cuz
guys when I couldn't sometimes
expressing ourselves maybe if you sit
down before you talk to her you write
down what would make you happy you write
down the point you want to make I used
to do this [ __ ] so I could I still
haven't mastered this but so I could
figure out how to [ __ ] have a
productive confrontation and I would
list all the points that I wanted to
make I would list what I wanted and then
I would draw a big stupid smiley face
reminding me not to be an angry [ __ ] so
I don't know if that helps you I hope it
did so anyways
as if there weren't enough tragedies
this month my [ __ ] my [ __ ] I don't
want happened they didn't record the f1
race today so I missed that Japan won I
did see the clip where for whatever
reason Lewis Hamilton and Sebastian
Vettel were like in some meeting in
front of all the other drivers like
telling on each other you know he took
his steering wheel off another guy's
like oh he took his seatbelt all those
loose that just maybe I just a slight
just I swear to god man
I it's like f1 is that like the soccer
of motor sports I can't but we what kind
of a [ __ ] I don't understand people
who they they have the balls to drive
200 miles an hour on each other's
[ __ ] bumpers staring death in the
face and then they go in there and they
[ __ ] telling on each other I just
that was really disappointing to see I
still love the sport it's such a great
[ __ ] sport but I don't know you know
what it is maybe it's just maybe that's
just it's too much access I don't need
to see that [ __ ] you know what I mean I
don't need to see that [ __ ] I don't
need to know all the [ __ ] ins and
outs the Rosie the riveters this guy
[ __ ] complain about this or that but
anyways convect congratulations to Lewis
Hamilton despite the fact you're telling
on people in meetings shamelessly maybe
that's like a [ __ ] European thing
like they just have different [ __ ]
rules over there you know what I mean
you can walk around in a banana hammock
[ __ ] speedo and that's just totally
acceptable [ __ ] telling on people I
mean I was just I was embarrassing I
don't know I don't [ __ ] know why did
I bring up how much I loved boozing now
I'm just thinking about getting one of
those custom mattresses number that
thing where they used to have the lady
jumping up and down on the mattress and
the guy would have the glass of red wine
and it wouldn't spill that's what I need
anyways I start uh I got some acting
work coming up here over the next
four or five weeks so I got at least
another 20 days on this whole not
boozing thing and I'm actually really
enjoying it I've dropped some weight and
[ __ ] I I do enjoy not drinking but I
will tell you this it's just night time
right now and it's [ __ ] difficult oh
look who's here
hey baby there ain't no easy way yeah I
won't back down you know I was one of
the great things I've ever seen in this
sporting event could you please say that
again it's me do your impression of me
again
the lovely Nia everybody I'm great
baby's asleep oh god what's going on
it's been a while yeah I got her all
amped up today didn't know yes you did
she had one nap for 30 minutes all day
that's ridiculous
week so we were excited to see each
other yeah she was excited to see you it
was cute hey guys are cute
yeah it's ridiculous I love that kid
obviously oh I already read this one
whoa this guy won all right I'll just
paraphrase these two things all right
well there was one guy right it's his
mom he's like 19 he lives at home and
his mom has a new boyfriend and he could
literally hear the headboard getting
[ __ ] yeah terrible terrible right
yeah and then if he could go stay with
his dad but his dad is always talking
about what a [ __ ] is you know a divorce
oh yeah so now he's thinking of just
like joining the [ __ ] Coast Guard
just so he'd know what I mean if you
want to but that seems like an awfully
extreme what'd she get a job in like
child world maybe yeah definitely try to
find his own place try to stay on land
didn't work it out yeah I think so I
don't think that you have to join
nothing there's anything wrong with the
Coast Guard
I think the Coast Guard yeah it's got to
be raining [ __ ] it's gotta be
how you kidding you walk around in
uniform you're on a boat you can serve
other dudes yeah then you but you're not
like you're not out to sea just any time
so it does it doesn't not count if
you're on a boat I mean it's just what
not count I don't know what you saying I
mean you know
oh right you know what I'm thinking I'm
thinking of the Navy the Coast Guard is
not the same as the Navy no it is it
what do you what do you what you said
when you said it doesn't count what do
you what do you mean it what doesn't
count like you know like when guys go to
jail and stuff like it doesn't count
like you're not like necessarily are you
talking about guys banging other guys
how did you get that and what does it
mean it doesn't count
who ever said where did you ever hear
that you ever bang a guy yeah it didn't
count I was out on a lake I feel like
for sexually flexible men or whatever
like if you're in an extreme situation
like jail or out to sea what in God's
name are you talking about these people
they go out so many tips over in an in
or to there's a drug dealer coming up
they go out and they [ __ ] them up and
then they come back yeah they go on a
patrol but this isn't like no no I got
confused I was I was thinking that it
was like the Navy why aren't you like
out on a boat right for months
yeah but the Navy then aren't they
[ __ ] each other they come into port
and then they bang a bunch of in the
Navy you can help your fellow man that
was the Village People all right do you
think Native Americans are gay cuz I one
guy with the headdress was going macho
macho man but they were singing about
like guy stuff
like places where there's groups men
together listen I've been to the YMCA I
never [ __ ] another guy I went there
and I used they're unbelievably old
workout equipment I played some pickup
hoop
I didn't see any gay sex happening there
all right
well fine obviously the Coast Guard is
not the same as the Navy but I was just
saying that if it was it would be fine
because it doesn't are you like high
right now
it sounds really high right now but I'm
not but like you can she's getting over
being sick by the way this isn't like
some smoker thing with her um yeah cuz
they're gonna be like oh she's got a
smoker's cough no I just uh I don't know
my point is I don't know what my point
was but I was saying you know my thing
is a Navy no I feel like he's in the
Coast Guard he's joined the Coast Guard
I figured that's just like a [ __ ]
like if you meet somebody in a bar I
would think it's a woman that guy said
he's in the Coast Guard that's like
being like you know women like firemen
it's like you're a fireman except you're
[ __ ] on a boat yeah and you're like
going there you go yeah it's hot think
that's what if that's what I was talking
about you need to go talk about jail sex
I don't want to [ __ ] that keep him from
is it enough this kid has to think of we
hear his mother getting banged up
against the [ __ ] headboard you got to
bring up [ __ ] prison sex you know
this podcast has taken a lot of left
turns throughout the years that was one
of the bigger ones all right well you
don't have to join the Coast Guard just
to get away from your but maybe you do I
don't know what is the Coast Guard do
they're like the cops of the water right
okay this is who I married everybody is
when you thought she was the brains of
the outfit we have a child that we're
gonna raise what is
the coastguard oh wait that's right
aren't they like the cops of the water
hey do they get upset when there's like
a tornado in a tornado tell me I'm a
[ __ ] hurricane hey settle down water
that'll be enough of that no they
actually do a lot of badass [ __ ] they
but people think they save people's
lives
they fly out there for all these [ __ ]
dopes but they are the cops of the water
I mean they would be insulted to hear me
say that a nicer way to say is they
guard the shores of this great country
can they oh that's nice can they arrest
oh good
so like [ __ ] that guy from for you do
can they arrest you the Coast Guard yes
I would love to see you with a giant
shipment of drugs when they pulled up
who are you guys do you guys like have
sex with each other oh you're the coast
oh wait you're like the cops of the
water wait can you arrest me I would pay
you [ __ ] all the money in the world
just to see the look in their [ __ ]
face I know I'm insulting so many Coast
Guard members officers no there's all
different ranks I imagine this there's
semen keep your mind out of the gutter
although we have two officers as
captains uh-huh you want me to I don't
we do this you know Nia when I don't
know stuff I just asked the internet and
whoever made a page on it then I just go
oh that's what it is that's what it is
okay the Coast Guard let's get it let's
get it I gotta go wiki on this so
they'll actually help me out here all
right okay the United States Coast Guard
is a service chief and highest-ranking
member oh this is the Commandant of the
code the United States Coast Guard sorry
your phone is vibrating over the United
States Coast Guard is a branch of the
United States Armed Forces and one of
the country's army yeah you you you you
can't save everything by saying of the
water Nia
you've been watching the Kardashians
show way too [ __ ] much here all right
Jesus all right one second the Coast
Guard is a maritime military multi
mission service unique among the u.s.
military branches for having maritime
law enforcement can they arrest people
with jurisdiction in both domestic and
international waters now there's a big
one I didn't know international so you
can't like outrun these [ __ ] and then
just sit there and make faces at them
the second you get out in international
waters I didn't know that then a federal
regular I thought once you went out in
international waters it was captain's
captain's law right
captain's log and a federal regulation
omission is part of the mission its
mission set it operates under the US
Department of Homeland Security during
peacetime and can be transferred to the
US Department of the Navy I see right so
I I didn't realize that they were then
activated I thought they were like the
like sort of the farm team like Triple A
of the Navy out of the water
loves the water yes you know there's a
lot of people laughing at us right now
and they didn't know that they could be
activated to the Navy I was just saying
this has happened twice that they were
made part of the Navy once in 1917
during World War one and another time
during World War two and that's
obviously you know Pearl Harbor happened
and then German u-boats and I don't know
what the [ __ ] happened in World War one
were there wooden ships off our coast
right no there weren't wooden ships at
that point okay
although the the [ __ ] biplanes are
made out of like Kleenex I think all
right I think that we've showed how dumb
we are
boo boo all right that's the podcast
everybody if you'd like to see this live
if you would actually like to see this
trainwreck live once again all things
comedy festival podcast all things what
is this all things comedy festival uh we
are having this on October 20 26 to the
29th in Phoenix Arizona I'm gonna be at
stand-up live on October 28th doing this
podcast live live live and there's been
a lot of people requesting that you're
there really but we got the kid oh so I
don't know if that happens where is it
it's in Arizona you want to fly to
Arizona to do a podcast for free mm-hmm
hey how funny was it the other day the
other day when you were getting sad and
you were starting to cry and I just kept
making that sad face which would then
make you laugh and then you couldn't cry
I hate when Nia cries because I don't
know what to do I told you that story
big tears big tears right so she was
talking I don't know what the [ __ ] she
was talking something about okay what
I'm talking about like you don't even
care you're just like make it stop yeah
it was she just started tearing up she's
like you know I wanted to talk to you
about something I'm just worried in the
future she started doing that and when
she did that I just made this I just
looked at I made a little sad face and
then she looked up and saw me then you
started [ __ ] laughing what was funny
is you had tears in your eyes when you
were laughing and then she kept trying
to go back to crying again no listen to
me I'm just trying to say and then I
would make the sad face again guys you
got to do that to your woman next time
she gets no look if it's something
[ __ ] serious it was so you you know
it wasn't yes it was it was silly I
thought it was trivial yeah exactly see
not everyone is gonna be as you know I
thought it was trivial because it was
coming to you dummy exactly exactly you
don't even know when it wasn't I was
concerned about you were concerned about
the cop
to the water yeah yeah you laugh it like
you baked the Coast Guard oh that's it
did the ship is sailed no pun intended
it's over
[Music]
alright fine
no don't don't don't give someone the
pouty face when they're coming to you
crying about an emotional issue that
they're feeling that's a terrible all
right then tell me what you were
concerned about I'll be immature now
good well you can serve up ah it was
about it's a good move because it keeps
you happy alright that's the podcast
that's the podcast I know we have the
creepy surveillance so you shot it with
like a dart or something
face down she's out take some Discovery
Channel when you want to tag an animal
alright that's the podcast for this
Monday go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in
on you on Thursday thank you everybody
came out to the shows this weekend this
weekend in st. Petersburg and I had a
great time once again out there cigar
capital of the u.s. Nene was [ __ ]
tremendous it was tremendous all right
I'll see you guys